storing bread in the refrigerator delays
drying and the growth of mold but
increase the rate at which the bread
loses flavor so that already felt a
little bit strange especially right
around here but let's think about why it
feels strange so what's the subject the
subject is storing bread in the
refrigerator it is singular it is a
singular action the singular action of
storing bread in the refrigerator this
right over here is singular we have a
singular subject and then we see it
right over here where later on and once
again the word delays isn't up for
debate they didn't underline this as a
potential error place but this is a
singular this is a singular
version of the word of the verb delay so
this right over here is also singular so
this verb right over here
this singular verb agrees with the
singular subject if you have a singular
subject let me do that same magenta
color
if you have a singular subject
then you should have a singular verb so
this makes sense storing bread in the
refrigerator delays drying in the growth
of mold but then over here we say but
increase
increase this is the this is the plural
form of the verb so this really should
be increases to make it singular to give
it the singular form of the word for it
to for this verb to agree with the
singular subject it needs to be but
increases the rate at which the bread
loses flavor so the error is definitely
where we suspect it it's in this little
the it's in this part of the sentence